il n'y a pas de risque sur les bons
françaises il n'y a pas de risque sur le
système bancaire français je veux le
dire à tous les notes parions à tous les
entrepreneurs qui ont déposé leurs fonds
auprès des banques françaises trois
banques ou Atlantique ont fait faillite
en quelques jours dans la 16e et la 21e
banque américaine la silicone va les
banques c'est en effet effondré en 48
heures vendredi 15 ans après la faille
de Lemon Brother les États-Unis n'ont
visiblement rien appris aussi peu cette
faillite ce n'est pas un accident c'est
la crise d'un système dans lequel nous
avons tous vécu au plan mondial celui de
l'argent soit disant gratuit c'est aussi
le signe que toutes les banques qu'elle
soit petite ou grande en fait ont des
effets systémiques
et qu'elles doivent à ce titre être
regardés comme ayant des effets
systémiques sur toutes les économie quel
que soit leur taille par le régulateur
la SVB la Silicon Valley Bank avait
trois caractéristiques 1 a été exposée à
un seul secteur d'activité le secteur
détectologie 2 elle avait comme seule et
unique placement les bons du Trésor
américain ce qui fait que lorsque les
taux ont remonté le placement était
moins positif des épargnants ont retiré
leurs avoir et la banque s'est retrouvée
à court de liquidité trois étaient
soumises qu'à la supervision du
superviseur de San Francisco un
superviseur régional puisque je le
rappelle seul 13 banques américaines sur
les 3500 banques américaines sont
soumises aux règles de supervision de
balles 3 là où 400 banques européennes
sont soumises aux règles de supervision
de balles 3 c'est-à-dire les règles les
plus strictes le système bancaire
français lui
un système universel avec six grandes
banques qui représentent plus de 90% des
dépôts des épargnants et des dépôts des
entreprises un système universel et un
système diversifié où chacune de ces
banques a déplacement qui sont très
diversifiés et avec des ratios de
liquidités des ratiaux de solvabilité
qui sont parmi les meilleurs au monde je
rappelle que les bancs françaises depuis
la crise que vous rappelez à juste titre
de 2008 ont 1550 milliards d'euros de
fonds propres supplémentaires
disponibles pour assurer le ratio de
solvabilité donc je veux vous rassurer
et à travers vous rassurer tous nos
compatriotes le système bancaire
français et solide et il n'y a pas de
risque sur les banques françaises